BOLSHEVIKS FOR BIDEN.
THAT’S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
ANGLE.
JOE BIDEN MADE A QUICK TRIP TO
FLORIDA TODAY.
HIS FIRST TIME IN THE SUNSHINE
STATE FOR NEARLY A YEAR.
TURNS OUT, HIS 2020 BASEMENT
STRATEGY HAS HIM LOOKING
VULNERABLE AND AT TIMES EVEN A
TAD CONFUSED.
>> HARRIS-BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
WILL RELAUNCH THAT EFFORT.
WHEN WE HIT THE RECESSION, THE
PRESIDENT -- PRESIDENT OBAMA --
FRIGHTENS PEOPLE WHEN I TALK
ABOUT THE TESTING AREA.
SHOOTING LIVE AMMO AND THINGS.
>> Laura: MEANWHILE, TRUMP IS
SIGNING HISTORIC PEACE ACCORDS,
GETTING TWO NOBEL PRIZE
NOMINATIONS AND CRISSCROSSES THE
COUNTRY.
OVER THE PAST 36 HOURS, THE
PRESIDENT WAS IN NEVADA FOR A
RALLY, CALIFORNIA TO DEAL WITH
THE WILD FIRES, ARIZONA FOR A
HISPANIC EVENT AND THEN BACK TO
WASHINGTON TO SIGN THE ABRAHAM
ACCORDS.
AFTER ALL THAT, HE THEN HEADED
TO PENNSYLVANIA FOR A TOWN HALL
TONIGHT WHICH WE’LL HAVE AS I
SAID FIRST REACTION LATER IN THE
HOUR.
TRUMP IS TRULY THE ENERGIZER
BUNNY OF POLITICS.
HE KEEPS GOING AND GOING.
FOR BIDEN THOUGH, A BIG DAY
IS -- I DON’T KNOW -- CASTING A
PRIMARY VOTE A FEW MINUTES DRIVE
FROM HIS HOME.
>> WHAT ABOUT EARLY VOTE
SOMETHING YOU GUYS VOTED EARLY
TODAY?
>> BECAUSE I’M GOING TO BE --
WHERE AM I TOMORROW?
>> FLORIDA.
>> TRAVELING TOMORROW.
>> Laura: SINCE BIDEN CAN’T TELL
US, IT’S IMPORTANT THAT WE
EXAMINE THE TWIN FORCES BEHIND
THE BIDEN CANDIDACY.
THE BILLIONAIRES AND THE
BOLSHEVIKS.
EXPLAIN WHAT EACH FACTION WANTS.
WHEN MICHAEL BLOOMBERG ANNOUNCED
THAT HE WAS GIVING THE BIDEN
CAMPAIGN $100 MILLION TO SPEND
IN FLORIDA, IT BECAME OBVIOUS
THAT THE BILLIONAIRE CLASS IS
GETTING A LITTLE NERVOUS.
SUDDENLY THE GOAL OF GETTING
BACK TO NORMAL AND OUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH CHINA, WHICH
IS WHAT THEY WANT, DOESN’T SEEM
SUCH A SURE BET AFTER ALL.
BLOOMBERG HATES THE TRUMP TARIFF
TARIFFS BECAUSE THEY MAKE IT
HARDER TO DO BIG DEALS IN CHINA.
HE’S ONE OF AT LEAST 132
PROMINENT BILLIONAIRES THAT ARE
SUPPORTING BIDEN.
FIRST, THERE’S BILL GATES.
HE SEEMS TO BE ROOTING FOR A
BIDEN WIN IN NOVEMBER AS WELL.
AFTER ALL, HE AND BIDEN SAME THE
SAME AGENDA.
THEY AGREE ON APIECING CHINA A
NATIONAL MASK MANDATE AND NO
RETURN TO NORMALCY WITHOUT A
VACCINE.
>> FOR THE WORLD AT LARGE,
NORMALCY ONLY RETURNS WHEN WE
LARGELY VACCINATED THE ENTIRE
GLOBAL POPULATION.
>> Laura: I LOVE HOW HE DOES
THIS WITH HIS HANDS.
THEN THERE’S TOM STIRE WHO IS A
PROMOTER OF THE GREEN NEW DEAL
WHICH WILL KILL THE OIL AND GAS
INDUSTRY.
THERE’S LAUREEN POWELL JOBS,
WHOSE MAGAZINE "THE ATLANTIC"
JUST PUBLISHED THAT BOGUS SMEAR
CLAIMING TRUMP BELITTLED THE WAR
DEAD.
FALSE.
THEY ALL HAVE ONE THING IN
COMMON.
THEY DESPISE PRESIDENT TRUMP’S
AMERICA FIRST AGENDA.
THE BILLIONAIRE CROWD PREFERS AN
AMERICA WHERE THERE’S ALWAYS A
GLUT OF LABOR.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
IT MEANS THERE’S NO PRESSURE ON
COMPANIES TO RAISE WAGES.
TRUMP PREFERS A TIGHT LABOR
MARKET THAT PUTS UPWARD PRESSURE
ON WAGES, MEANING BRINGING THEM
UP.
THAT’S GOOD FOR THE AVERAGE
WORKING PERSON.
BESIDES, THE BILLIONAIRES DON’T
NEED A FUNCTIONING GOVERNMENT.
THEY DON’T HAVE TO WORRY MUCH
ABOUT LAW AND ORDER.
THEY HAVE SECURITY GUARDS AND
BIG WALLS AND HELICOPTERS AND
PLANES IF THEY WANT TO ESCAPE.
BUT NOT THE AVERAGE PERSON.
CHECK OUT THIS HEADLINE.
PENNSYLVANIA’S BLUE COLLAR
VOTERS SEE DANGER AND BACK
TRUMP.
THESE SAME WORKERS, THEY KNOW
THE TRUTH.
TRUMP’S ECONOMIC NATIONALISM
WORKS.
THESE SAME WORKERS KNOW THE
TRUTH THAT TRUMP’S ECONOMIC
NATIONALISM IS NOTHING THAT
BIDEN WOULULD EVER AGREE TO.
IN FACT, HE WORKS AGAINST IT.
CHECK OUT THIS HEADLINE.
"MEDIAN HOUSEHOLD INCOME
INCREASED 6.8% TO $68,700, THE
HIGHEST ON RECORD.
THE NATION’S POVERTY RATE FELL
BY 1.3 POINTS TO 10.5%."
THAT WAS 2019.
THIS MARKED THE LOWEST RATE
SINCE ESTIMATES WERE FIRST
PUBLISHED IN 1959.
IT WAS THE FIFTH CONSECUTIVE
DECLINE.
NOW, THIS WAS REAL MONEY IN
AMERICAN’S POCKETS ALL BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC.
IF BIDEN WINS, THERE’S GOING TO
BE NO REPEATING THE 2019
FANTASTIC NUMBERS BECAUSE WE’LL
BE IN LOCKDOWN AS I SAID LAST
NIGHT WITH MASSIVE JOB LOSSES
AND STAGNATING WAGES.
WE’LL BE HIT WITH A $4 TRILLION
TAX INCREASE AS WELL.
THE ONLY THING THAN WILL TRICKLE
DOWN FROM ALL OF THIS IS
POVERTY.
GOVERNMENT DEPENDENCE.
THE OTHER FORCE SUPPORTING BIDEN
ARE THE MODERN DAY BOLSHEVIKS.
THE AOC TYPES.
THEY BELIEVE THAT AMERICA IS AN
AWFUL, ROTTEN RACIST COUNTRY.
THEY PLAN TO PUNISH ANYONE THAT
GETS IN THE WAY OF THEIR
CULTURAL REVOLUTION.
AOC’S TWEET YESTERDAY IS
CHARACTERISTIC OF HOW SHE FEELS
ABOUT US.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS, THE
UNITED STATES IS ENGAGED IN A
PROGRAM OF MASS HUMAN RIGHTS
VIOLATIONS TARGETING IMMIGRANTS.
THIS INCLUDES PEOPLE IN
DETENTION AND MORE.
OUR COUNTRY MUST ATONE FOR IT
ALL.
OF COURSE, SHE’S TALKING ABOUT
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS, NOT LEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
THE RADICAL FRINGE, THEY ARE
GOING TO LET BILLIONAIRES RUN
ECONOMIC POLICY AS LONG AS THEY
CAN RUN EVERYTHING ELSE.
SO AOC’S FINE AS LONG AS SHE CAN
DO CLIMATE POLICY, HAVE A SAY IN
THE COURTS, THE DOJ.
THAT IS BECAUSE THEY’LL USE
EVERY TOOL IN THE GOVERNMENT’S
POWER TO HARASS AMERICANS WHO
DEFY THE SOCIALIST EDICTS.
IT’S GOING TO BE A LONG, DARK
PERIOD OF RECRIMINATIONS AND
RETRIBUTION.
DON’T THINK FOR A SECOND THAT
BIDEN OR KAMALA HARRIS OR ANYONE
ELSE WILL EVEN TRY TO SLAM THE
BRAKES ON AS WE SPEED TOWARDS
SOCIALISM.
>> THIS IS OUR TIME TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE GET RID OF TRUMP AND WE
ELECT SOMEONE THAT WILL BE
RESPONSIVE TO THE POLICY
POSITIONS WE ARE ADVOCATING FOR.
>> JOE BIDEN HAS PUT PROBABLY
THE BOLDEST PLAN IN MY LIFETIME
TO BE BY 2035 CARBON NEUTRAL.
>> WHAT CAME OUT OF THOSE TASK
FORCES WERE PRETTY STRONG
PROGRESSIVE PROGRAMS.
JOE BIDEN IS PREPARED TO DO
THAT.
>> Laura: NOW, BIDEN IS BEING
PROPPED UP BY THE ENERGY OF THE
LEVEL THAT LULLS AMERICA MORN
THAN IT LIKES HIM ALONG WITH THE
MONEY OF SOME OF THE RICHEST MEN
AND WOMEN ON THE PLANET.
NEITHER THE BILLIONAIRES, NOR
THE BOLSHEVIKS HAVE MUCH
INTEREST IN BUILDING A STRONG
MIDDLE CLASS.
THE BILLIONAIRES DON’T LIKE
WORKERS THAT CAN THINK FOR
THEMSELVES AND THE BOLSHEVIKS
DON’T LIKE THE MASSES TO BE
INDEPENDENT OF GOVERNMENT
CONTROL.
THEY FORM KIND OF AN UNHOLY
ALLIANCE.
TO TURN THE WHOLE COUNTRY INTO A
GIANT VERSION OF BALTIMORE WITH
A TINY NUMBER OF RICH PEOPLE AND
A LOT OF POOR PEOPLE.
THE MIDDLE CLASS, GUESS WHAT?
THEY STILL GET TO VOTE.
IF WE WANT TO PRESERVE OUR WAY
OF LIFE, IF WE WANT TO KEEP THE
GOOD JOBS THAT HAVE BEEN CREATED
AND THE FREEDOMS THAT AMERICANS
HAVE ENJOYED FOR CENTURIES,